I don't think so mean it's part of a
process of gaining evidence for the
report we're doing on the situation
bombardier in Northern Ireland but it
certainly didn't bring any revelations
the central contention that Boeing is
making is that the Bombardier CSeries
aircraft is competing with its 737
unfairly and it's taking the Canadian
government and the UK government to task
over that I think the evidence we
gathered today has suggested that our
impression that that is not true is
probably right and that these two
aircraft don't compete therefore Boeing
is not sustaining any loss as a result
of the situation and I hope very much
therefore that when the matter is
considered by the US authorities shortly
that it will consider that Boeing's
claim is unfounded whether or not one
believes that the CSeries is competing
with the 737 it is the case so that
Bombardier has been selling aircraft in
the United States below cost well that
is what Boeing Boeing will contend the
fact of the matter is this case rests on
whether boeing has sustained loss as a
result and it's pretty clear to me that
these two aircraft do not compete and
therefore it's not possible for Boeing
to her state sustained a loss and
certainly it's it's important always to
underscore the centrality of Bombardier
and short brothers in Belfast to the
economy there in terms of security it's
of vital importance and it's desperately
important that UK ministers continue
doing what they have been doing and that
is underscoring the importance of
Bombardier to the economy in Northern
Ireland to security in Northern Ireland
and I am confident they will do so with
their interlocutors in the States and
hopefully we'll move into a far better
place but at the moment this threat to
jobs at Short brothers in Northern
Ireland in Belfast is a clear and
present danger and I hope common sense
will ultimately prevail Boeing argues
that it's been made escape
goat for the financial shortcomings at
Bombardier they do have a point though
don't they I don't think so at all
Bombardier produces a high quality
product in Belfast it's something that
can only be done in Belfast that's of
enormous value to any player in the
aerospace sector I hope very much that
Boeing even at this late stage will
recognize the importance of what happens
in Belvoir Belfast and withdraw its
claims before it reaches the authorities
in the US now Canada Bombardier zone
country of course has today pulled an
order for fighter jets from Boeing
because of this route would you like to
see the Ministry of Defence do something
similar over here well to be clear the
f18 order had not actually been placed
it was more of an aspiration as I
understand it
I think ministers are being pretty
robust very robust in its condemnation
of the Boeing position and I think it's
quite likely that in the event that
further work came up in the defense
sector in this country we would have the
ministers would have to look closely at
whether it was in our interest to pursue
those options rather than pursue others
so Boeing I think is on notice that it
cannot take work in this country for
granted and I'm very pleased with the
uncompromising position that Arminius
have taken on this of course if the
Ministry of Defence were to do something
like that it potentially could
jeopardize the 2,200 jobs that Boeing
has here in the UK well interestingly my
Select Committee took evidence from the
union Unite and I put this point to them
and they acknowledged it but not
withstanding the possible threat to jobs
and the wider UK felt that this was such
importance to Bombardier in Belfast
rightly sir my opinion that they really
had to go 100% to protect their members
in in in Northern Ireland I think the
point is this goes beyond the strictly
commercial this extends into the
security of Northern Ireland because of
the vital importance of so many private
sector jobs in Belfast
consequentials for a whole raft of other
businesses that rely completely on
Bombardier